in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Bob and
Jan are with us hey guys how are you
doing good right today
welcome welcome where you guys from we
are from Aiken South Carolina that's
north near Augusta Georgia very cool and
you are here to do your debt-free screen
we are and how much debt of you guys
paid us so it was about $70,000
and it was in the last two years 23
months okay very good and your range of
income during that years um I've made
about 160 a year and my wife is not not
working outside the home okay
very cool what do you do for a living
I'm a software developer know very good
good for you excellent well done $70,000
yeah what did you buy well this was
basically the home mortgage oh you paid
off your house absolutely and in 2008 my
wife's stepfather passed away and so her
mom basically we had a home built for
her on our property and so I basically
went and got a home equity line of
credit to do that purchase of a little
cottage home for her okay so I had the
home mortgage as well as a home equity
line of credit so we were a total 70,000
little 70,000 and that was the only debt
you guys have that's right so I lo paid
for house I thought we were I thought we
were doing pretty good before we took
FPU but I'm here to tell you even people
who aren't necessarily in trouble can
also benefit from financial peace for
sure absolutely well thank you yeah
because you guys were in pretty good
shape right you just so what's the
property worth so it's worth about three
hundred thousand okay with the cottage
and everything oh yeah yeah very cool
very cool that's nice
and how old are you - you have a
paid-for house exactly we're in our late
50s awesome very cool that's that's
exactly the way it should be
how's it feel to have that whole thing
paid for oh it's definitely it's freeing
it's a relief you know what happened 23
months ago that made you look up and go
you know we have 70,000 we can knock
this out well to be honest it was
basically just some friends got together
at church and and we're going to take
the financial peace classes you know it
was being offered by the church and we
said sure we'll come along you know
camaraderie type thing didn't really
feel like we needed it like I said we
weren't in trouble but we definitely
learned a whole lot of things you'll get
a kick out of this my emergency fund was
basically that home equity line of
credit oh yeah I actually addressed that
any one of the tapes right at you yeah
that's perfect I was talking now the TV
right at you so so we we learned a lot
from that and then basically as you
talked about being a gazelle you know
gazelle like attitude towards your debt
towards your mortgage it was basically
every dime every extra dollar we could
scrape together went toward the mortgage
part of the debt payment in the budget
but knowing that you're gonna be
completely free in a very short period
of time that's very well done very very
well done
okay so FPU Financial Peace University
set you on the last step of your
financial here because you were already
there and now that it's paid off you
have all this money I mean you can give
and live and invest and become wealthy I
mean you're gonna be an incredible
condition exactly yep very well done
forward to well congratulations you too
what do you tell people the secret to
getting out of debt is basically just
being open having an open mind to you
know you don't necessarily know it all
you don't necessarily have all the right
answers just you know having an open
mind and then basically like I said
being a gazelle being you know steadfast
and just you know stay at it that's
absolutely that was one of the other
things is that I you know found myself
handling all the finances and just not
sharing that with my wife and so we it's
part of FPU we did it together how did
that change things change it really made
me feel not left out after being married
29 years I felt left out because he
would say I can handle it which he did
handle it well mm-hmm and had no
question about that but I felt left out
mm-hmm and since your which took your
class it made me feel apart financially
a part of our our our life so that
helped the relationship absolutely even
after 29 years that's awesome well
congratulations you guys very proud of
you very
well done all right Bob and Jan from
Augusta Georgia everything's made off
house and everything
mother-in-law cottage everything $70,000
paid off in 23 months making 160 a year
count it down
let's hear a debt free scream 3 2 1
we are debt-free well done you guys very
very well done I love it I love it I
love it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind